The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So
today, we are going
to talk about the midget
and parasol channels.
I will begin by reminding you
of what these two channels are
that I very briefly
talked about before.
Namely, if you look at the
Golgi stain of cross sections
of the retina, when you look
at just the ganglion cells,
it was discovered
initially by the inventors,
if you will, of the
Golgi stain, namely,
Golgi himself and Cajal.
Cajal did this, initially.
And then, subsequently, a
fellow whose name is down here,
Polyak, has used the same
technique to study the retina.
And what he discovered
was-- not Polyak initially,
but Cajal initially
discovered, and then was
verified by Polyak using
these anatomical techniques,
namely, the Golgi
stain-- that there's
one class of cells that have
very small dendritic arbors,
as you can see here,
and another set that
has much, much larger arbors.
Now, once this was
discovered, subsequently when
it became possible to
record from individual cells
and to study their
receptive fields
and their basic organization,
and also to look
at them from a
different point of view,
it was, first of
all, shown that these
are two very distinct
classes of cells
in terms of the dendritic
arbors they create.
And as I mentioned
to you before,
these cells are
called parasol cells
because the dendritic arbors
look like an umbrella.
And at comparable
eccentricities,
the midget cells are three
times smaller in diameter
than are the so-called
parasol cells.
And then I showed you
some data the last time
indicating that these
two types of cells
conduct at different velocities
to the central nervous system,
with these bigger cells
having bigger axons conducting
significantly faster
than the midget cells,
and that you get a
distribution when you record
from all the axons in the
retinal geniculate pathway
that they form separate
populations because, initially,
the argument was that
maybe this is just
a continuous
population of cells.
But it turns out
these are indeed
two very distinct classes
on the anatomical level
as well as the conduction
velocity level.
Then when it became possible
to record from single neurons
and to study their
receptive fields,
it was shown-- I
showed you this picture
before as well--
that you have, first
of all, center-surround
organization as discovered
by Kuffler; and secondly, that
the midget and parasol cells
are very different in size as
far as the receptive fields
are concerned as well
as the dendritic arbors;
and that the midget
cells in central retina
receive an input from
just a single cone,
whereas the parasol cells
got a multiple input.
And another distinction
that was, at that time, made
is that the neuronal
responses are
such that midget cells respond
in a much more sustained
fashion when you
activate the center
mechanism than do
the parasol cells.
So these respond much
more transiently.
So this, then, were
initial cues as to what
might be involved as to why
we have these two systems.
And there were all
kinds of hypotheses.
And then, eventually,
in the '60s and '70s
and especially in the '80s and
'90s, all kinds of experiments
were carried out to
try to establish just
why these two separate
systems have evolved.
So now, when the anatomical
work was further progressing,
it was found, as I have
mentioned also the last time
to you, that each cone in
the retina-- certainly true
for the red and the
green cones, which
would be equivalent
to the midget system--
gives rise to an ON and
an OFF bipolar cell.
Those are the ones we
discussed the last time.
What I did not
discuss the last time,
and I'm not going to
discuss today either
but will the next time we
talk about color perception,
is that the blue
cones-- how many of you
remember what is the frequency
of blue cones in the retina?
AUDIENCE: 1 in 8.
PROFESSOR: 1 in 8.
Very good.
Excellent.
So that being the case, that
already makes them different
because the numerosity's
so much lower.
And then people have done
all kinds of recordings,
and to this day,
it's not quite clear
what the connection
or pattern is.
But as I said, next time,
we will talk about it
in some detail when
we talk about color.
But here, don't get frightened,
we will discuss this
the next time.
But at any rate, we
have the blue cones.
And when we talk
about color opponency
that I will explain
the next time,
we think of the opponency
to blue being yellow,
and the opponency
to red being green.
And so the assumption
here was made
that the connections
in this case,
somehow, must take place
to create color opponency.
And since we have only three
kinds of cones in the retina,
in the primate-- red,
green, and blue--
the opponency here
must, somehow,
involve both the
red and green cones.
So that's the complication that
we will discuss the next time.
And so the assumption
was made that we
have some so-called yellow/blue
cells and blue/yellow cells.
And so I just want
to keep you puzzled
as to what this
means, especially
what it means with respect
to how we can see colors.
And that's what we will
talk about the next time.
So now, here we have,
by contrast-- and we
go back here-- here, this
is, then, the midget system.
And I showed you
the two extremes,
which are very clear,
and in between, which
would be somehow
creating the blue system.
So that's the midget system
with very small receptive fields
and very small cells.
Now, by contrast, when you look
at the parasol system, what
you see here is, as indicated
by the picture I showed you
just a minute ago, is that the
receptive fields are bigger.
The ganglion cell's
a lot bigger.
And the dendritic arbors
are much more extensive.
Now, that means, by the
way-- I shouldn't even say
"by the way"-- that
means, very importantly,
that the ON and OFF bipolar
cells that connect with the ON
and OFF cells of the parasol
system are also much bigger
and have much more extensive
arbors, dendritic arbors,
because they sample many
cells instead of just one.
But overall, what this
means is that when
you look at the bipolar
cells in the retina,
there are about three
times as many bipolar cells
than there are photoreceptors.
Now, if you think
about this-- somebody
remembered the last
time-- that in the retina,
we have about 50
million cones, and we
have about 120 to 150 rods.
And so, then, if you think
about the fact, at least,
for the cone system, we have
three times as many bipolar
cells.
This only applies fully
to the cone system.
That still means that we
have 150 million bipolar
cells in the retina.
So it's absolutely
incredible, then,
this tiny little thing that
you have in your head, which
is less than an
inch in diameter,
you have these millions and
millions and millions of cells.
Amazing.
So this is then the arrangement
for the parasol system.
And now, we can
progress and make
another point about how
clever the wiring became
in the course of evolution.
The cleverness here
is that, as you know,
we only have a single layer
of photoreceptors, which,
outside the fovea, has
a mix of rods and cones.
But then if you look at the
receptive fields of ganglion
cells, what you find is that
they have overlapping receptive
fields for many
of the attributes.
So you have overlapping
for ON and OFF, of course.
And that's obvious
from the wiring.
But you also have
overlap for the midget
and the parasol cells.
And lastly, there's an
overlap-- even if you just
look at the rod
input-- which results
in realizing that the
receptive fields become larger
during dark adaptation by virtue
of the connections of the rod
photoreceptors to the rod
bipolars than to the A,
to amacrine cells, which then
connect with the same ganglion
cells as do the cones.
So this is, then, an
incredibly clever arrangement
which enables you to see
things extremely well.
And it's an incredible
feat of wiring
that accomplish this
incredible arrangement.
So now, another important
thing to consider, in addition
to what I've said so
far about the midget
and the parasol
cells, is that they
have distribution over space.
If you look at it from, say,
from the center of the eye,
meaning the fovea,
going to the periphery,
the ratio of midget and parasol
cells changes dramatically.
In the center
here, in the fovea,
you have a huge difference
in number of cells.
But as you get to the periphery,
these two types of cells
eventually become
equally numerous.
Now, to show this
in relationship
to the lateral
geniculate nucleus--
again, to repeat, in the fovea,
you have an 8 to 1 ratio;
in the periphery, they
have 1 to 1 ratio.
And this is directly reflected
in the lateral geniculate
nucleus.
Everything I've shown you
so far about the geniculate
was a six-layered structure.
But those six layers
exist only to about
an 18-degree eccentricity
from the fovea.
And after that, the
lateral geniculate nucleus
becomes a four-layered
structure.
And as done here in
a schematic fashion,
the four layers for
the left and right eyes
are pretty much
equal in numerosity.
And that creates,
then, the 1 to 1 ratio.
So that makes one think,
why do we have this shift?
There must be something very
important in central vision
for which the midget
system is good for.
And in peripheral retina,
the parasol system
becomes more important.
So we are going to
pay attention to that
as we examine what the functions
are of these two systems.
So how do we go
about finding out
the functions of
these two systems?
Well, there are several methods.
The first one I'm
going to tell you about
is to record from individual
neurons-- say, in the cortex--
and determine what
kinds of inputs
they get from the midget
and the parasol cells.
So to do that, you first want
to look at the exact projections
of the retinal
ganglion cells again.
Just to remind you, here's the
lateral geniculate nucleus,
again, in the region where
there are six layers.
I already showed you
this picture before.
And I told you that the
parvocellular layers project
to 4C alpha; the magnocellular
layers to 4C beta;
and those other cells, which
we'll talk about eventually,
its lateral layers project to
the upper parts of the cortex.
So now, we have a
good idea that even
if the inputs to the
visual cortex-- meaning,
in this case, of course,
the V1-- the two systems are
separate in the input
layers, in 4C alpha and beta.
And then the question
comes up, well,
what happens when you look at
cells above and below the input
layers?
Do they converge?
Or what's going on?
So that's the kind of
questions we're going to ask.
And we are going to
look at this more
carefully here to find
out just how do you
do an experiment like that.
Well, one thing you can do here,
you can use a reversible agent
that you can inject either
in the parvocellular
or magnocellular layers
of the geniculate.
And if you do that, if in
the parvocellular layers,
this would be a blocking agent.
Xylocaine is something
that's used frequently.
There are several other agents.
And so if you inject
that substance in here,
you render the cells in the
geniculate unresponsive.
It's to serve the same idea
as what we talked about
with APB in the last time,
except this is not quite as
neat because it's
not a pure chemical
treatment like you did with APB.
Secondly, you can do it in the
magnocellular layers as well
and block that region.
Now, if you do this
kind of experiment,
let's first talk about
what happens in area of V1.
Now, this is a very difficult
and complicated experiment.
Sometimes, you can spend days
recording from a single animal
because, first of all,
what you have to do
is you have to put in electrodes
into the lateral geniculate
nucleus, which is way down,
preferably into both regions,
but there are many experiments
just to one or the other.
And then put an
electrode into V1.
Now, the next important
task, of course,
is that you've got to record
from V1 in the region to which
these cells or
these cells project.
So to find that overlap
in the receptive fields
that you need to do when
you record here, here,
and here is that you have
to take many, many electrode
penetrations until, finally,
you have an overlap.
And once you have
that overlap, you
can be sure that when you
inactivate this region
by injecting the
Xylocaine, you can
assess what the
responses are in the V1
before, during, and
after the injection.
And most importantly, before
and during, naturally.
So let's look at that.
This has been done
studying many cells
to get an overview
of what's going on.
And I'm going to
show you, initially,
just one example of
a cell to give you
a feel for what that's like.
So here we have
the cell respond.
What you do is you
take a bar of light
and move it across the
receptive field-- brrp,
brrp-- for each edge.
So those are the two
cumulative responses.
[INAUDIBLE]
That's the normal.
Now, you inject into the
parvocellular portions
of the geniculate.
And lo and behold, the
cell keeps responding.
Then you inject into
the magno portions.
And then lo and behold, the
cell still keeps responding.
But when you inject
into both-- bango!
There's no response.
So that means that
this particular cell
gets a convergent input from
the midget and the parasol cells
as they pass through the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
Now, if one then does
a systematic study
and then records from many
cells, what has been found here
is that some cells do
get an exclusive input
from the midget cells.
Some get an exclusive input
from the parasol cells.
And some are just like the one
I've shown you here-- namely,
they get a convergent input.
So that tells us, then, what
the very, very basic nature is
of the input to the visual
cortex, you, to some degree,
keep separate the two systems.
And to some degree,
you also have
a condition where
they are united.
So that's what
happens in area V1.
So now, the next thing
you are going to ask
is, well, what happens
in other cortical areas?
So here, then, I'm showing
you the same method picture.
But now, you have
recording in V4 and MT,
doing the similar
kinds of injections
that I just described in the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
So when one does this,
some interesting results
had been obtained.
And as always, before
this kind of experiment
that actually tested
this question,
there were, of
course, hypotheses.
Some people
hypothesized that area
of V4, which had
at one time been
proclaimed to be a
color area-- and we'll
come back to that shortly--
it was claimed, therefore,
that this area gets input
only from the midget system.
And this area-- since it
has motion-selective cells,
if you remember-- only gets
input from the parasol cells.
So, therefore, we can
now have the acid test,
thanks to some
remarkable work that
had been done, much
of it by John Maunsell
over at Harvard,
who had actually
worked here at MIT before then.
And he did an
experiment like that.
And here's an example of a
single cell recording from V4.
This is a magno block, and
this is the parvo block.
This is before the block,
and this is after the block.
So what you can see
here, this cell, again,
response to a bar
moving across-- brrp,
brrp-- like that.
Here are the two
responses shown here as
to how they come across
the receptive field.
And you can see a vigorous
response after you do this
and before you inject
Xylocaine into the geniculate
to block, in this
case, the magno system;
and in this case,
the parvo system.
This is backwards from the
way I usually presented.
I usually like to
put parvo first.
Preference-- it's the bias.
At any rate, you
can see what happens
is dramatic for this particular
cell after you injected,
you blocked the magno system.
The cell-- we said has
spontaneous activity--
but it no longer
responds to the edges.
By contrast, when
you do a parvo block,
you only get a small effect.
There is a reduction for
this particular cell,
but it's still responding.
So that is the example of
a recording in area of V4.
Now, let us go and ask the
question, what about MT?
Now, here's an example.
Same arrangement-- magno first,
parvo second, before the block,
after the block.
In this case, in
MT, you get a cell
that totally stopped
responding after magno block
to this moving stimulus.
And here, what you see
is after parvo block,
the response continues.
So now, this is just two cells.
Now, to be sure that these
two cells are generally
representative of these
observations, what you need
to do is to collect this kind
of information from many cells,
and then come up with a
qualitative statement.
So what you can do is
you can, for each cell,
when you do this
experiment, you can't
determine how much the cell
fired here to the stimulus
and how much it fired here.
And then you can get a
ratio of that response.
You can turn it into, like,
a percentage or maybe just
to score them as 0 to 1 number.
And then if you do that
for a whole bunch of cells,
what you find is shown here.
This is a bunch of cells in V4.
This is a bunch of cells in MT.
And what you can see here
is that in V4, first of all,
you have a medium degree
of blockage, nothing major,
but some blockage.
But most importantly,
you get blockage
both for parvocellular and
magnocellular inactivation.
By contrast, in
MT, what you find
is that when you block
magnocellular geniculate,
most of the cells are
dramatically affected.
Only a few cells are blocked
as a result of a parvocellular
block.
So the outcome of this is
that the hypothesis pertaining
to MT, that it gets mostly an
input from the parasol system,
is correct.
But the idea that V4
gets an input only
from the midget system
is obviously incorrect,
showing that it gets
an input from both.
So to then summarize
the wiring diagram here,
what you have here is
the eye, of course.
And then you have the
midget and parasol cells
that project, respectively,
to the parvocellular
and magnocellular layers of
the lateral geniculate nucleus,
then they go off to the cortex.
And if you remember,
in the cortex,
they terminated
4C alpha and beta.
And then, also, as I told
you, up here, you already
have many cells above and
below the input layers
that get a convergent input from
the midget and parasol cells.
So what happens then, in terms
of the projections to higher
cortical areas-- to talk
about V2, for example--
you get some cells
which are purely
driven by the midget
system, some cells purely
driven by the parasol, and many
cells that are driven by both.
So V2 becomes very
complicated because they
have different subdivisions.
Maybe in V2-- we talked
about it a little bit--
that may be receiving
different input from area of V1
in terms of whether
they are driven
by the midget or
the parasol cells.
Now, most notably, when
from V2 and from V1,
you look at the
projections to area MT,
the middle temporal
area, what you find
is that this is
heavily dominated
by the input from
the parasol cells.
Then if you go beyond
that, this continues
to the parietal lobe from MT.
But then, when you
go from V2 to V4,
then temporal, then the
frontal lobe, what you
find that there's
a mix of inputs
from both of these systems.
So it highlights the fact
that, indeed, these things
are quite complicated.
And so we need to now
turn to a different method
to try to ferret out beyond just
establishing the connections
as to what on earth these
two systems are for.
And needless to say, hypotheses
were rampant about this.
And what I'm going
to do now, I'm
going to tell you about
how one can go about
and how many investigators have
gone about trying to determine
what the functions are of
these two systems in processing
visual information.
So how do you do that?
Well, the way you
do that is you can
use what is called
lesion studies.
What you can do is
you can selectively
block either the
parvocellular or magnocellular
systems at the level of
lateral geniculate nucleus
because, by lucky happenstance,
the parvocellular layer is
getting input from midget,
and the magnocellular layer is
from the from the parasol cells.
So you can make lesions, then.
How do you make lesions?
There are variety of
ways of making lesions.
That's a huge field.
It applies not only to vision,
to many, many other areas,
to try to make carefully
selective lesions
in various parts of the brain.
Now, it's not easy to do
that in the geniculate.
So what you have to
do is, again, you
go in to the lateral geniculate
nucleus with a microelectrode.
Once you do that--
you already know
the layout of the
geniculate-- you
can find out where the
receptive fields are located,
and you can
determine whether you
are recording from the
parvocellular or magnocellular
layers.
You're going to adjust
the depth of the electrode
to be either in the
parvocellular or magnocellular
layers.
And once you have established
the receptive field location
and were certain about in
what parts of the geniculate
you are recording, you can
then proceed to make a lesion.
Now, there are a number
of ways of making lesions.
One of them is
called heat lesions.
You should take a
metal microelectrode.
You take it down
there, and then you
pass some current to make
the tip of the electrode hot,
you can affect, as you know,
maybe a millimeter area
or something like that in the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
I'm talking about
small, small areas.
Another alternative that you
can use is to inject a chemical.
One of those commonly used
is called Ibotenic acid,
which is a very nice attribute,
that when it causes a lesion,
the borders are nicely
clearly defined.
So no matter how you
do this, then once it
is done in a monkey, then you
can study a monkey for months
on end to see what
the vision is,
of how the vision is affected.
And then after you've done
that, you then process the brain
and look at the lateral
geniculate nucleus
to see what was the size
and location of the lesion.
Now then, in some cases, it's
"Oh, my god, you did both.
Nyah, nyah, nyah."
You screwed up.
So months and months of
work goes down the toilet.
But in some cases,
you get a good effect.
And that, eventually,
if you do it
several times on
several monkeys can
result in a solid publication.
So that is the basic process
for making the lesions.
Now, let me then
move on and broach
the next important
topic-- namely,
what are you going to study?
So what you have to study since
you want to have an open mind
and you don't want to say, "oh,
yeah, everything in the brain
does color" or
something like that,
and so instead of
just studying color,
you have to study
many other aspects.
So I'm going to tell you
about several kinds of tests
that have the newest.
And I will explain
each of those to you.
But first, I will list them.
The behavioral task that
is used-- very important--
is that you've got to be able
to confine the crucial stimulus
either to the area
that you had blocked
or the area that is intact.
So one way to do that,
which is the easiest way,
is to use a detection task.
We already talked
about that briefly.
The monkey first fixates.
That confines his
looking to that location.
And then you can present
a stimulus like this.
And if he makes a
saccade to it, he
gets a drop of apple
juice for a reward.
Now, that is a procedure.
And then, of course,
our next trial,
it appears someplace else.
On each trial, it's in
different locations.
And on some trials, you
can present the stimulus
in the area that
had been blocked.
You get it from by
magnocellular or parvocellular
lesions or infusions
or in an intact area.
And that, then, enables
you to compare performance
in regions where the monkey's
performance is normal
because he's intact and in those
regions where he lacks either
an input from the magnocellular
or from the parvocellular
layers of the lateral
geniculate nucleus,
meaning from the midget
and parasol cells.
So now, another
task which is used
to be able to carry out a
more thorough examination
of visual capacities
is his discrimination.
In which case,
after fixation, you
have a whole bunch
of stimuli coming on.
This is very effective
for studying color.
And in this case, this
discrimination task often
is called the so-called
oddities task.
That's an easy way
to remember it.
"Oddity" because this is odd.
All the others, the distractors,
if you will, are the same.
Only one stimulus is different.
And, of course, the monkey
has to make a direct saccade
to this stimulus to get a drop
of apple juice for reward.
So that would be a so-called
discrimination task.
So these are the two basic
tasks that can be used.
And now, we can proceed and ask
the question of what exactly,
what kinds of visual
capacities should be studied?
So let me just say one
more thing, by the way.
The way this is
done in a laboratory
is that you have a performance
monitor, so-called,
where the computer puts a square
around each of the dots that
will have appeared--
in this case,
this should be
discrimination-- or where
they will appear singly
in the detection task.
And if the monkey
makes a saccade that
lends the saccadic eye movement,
which you are recording,
into the square area
there, then automatically
a drop of apple
juice is discharged.
But if he were to make a
similar saccade to here,
he will not get
rewarded because this
is the only correct position.
And on each trial, that's
going to be someplace else.
Everybody understands
the method?
It's fairly straightforward.
So now, we can move on
and look at an example
of the kinds of lesions
that this can create.
Here is a lateral
geniculate nucleus again,
the six-layered portion.
And you can see this area
here, that this is a lesion.
There are no cells
functional here,
which affects only the
parvocellular layers.
You see here the two
magnocellular layers
are normal.
So this is the lesion
area which affects
a few degrees of visual
angle-- in this case,
in the lower part
of the visual field.
Now, here we have
a magno lesion.
If you just look
at this quickly,
you say, what lesion
are you talking about?
But if you look closely,
can you see this here?
There are no cells here.
So this is the region where both
layers, magnocellular layers
that get the input
from the parasol cells,
had been blocked.
So that is the block there.
So this is, then, an example
of a successful lesion.
And once you do these
kinds of experiments--
some of these experiments
can take a couple of years,
maybe longer-- you end up
having some monkeys who
have neat lesions like
this, then it's a control.
Let me just add
that, which I'm not
going to show any pictures of.
But you can also make,
on purpose, a lesion
where you block both of
them-- both the magno
and the parvocellular layers.
You just block out a portion
of the lateral geniculate
completely.
Now, that's an
important control.
For all kinds of experiments,
controls are essential.
Now, let me tell you-- this
is available in the published
material that you have
been asked to read--
that when you block
both magno and parvo,
maybe a quarter of the
lateral geniculate nucleus,
whenever you present stimuli in
the area that has a topographic
correspondence to
the lesion's region,
the monkey cannot see a thing.
He cannot perform any
of those tasks at all.
So clearly, whatever
effect one gets here
with these selective
lesions can then
be ascribed-- if you see
deficit after this one
or deficit after that one--
can be ascribed to what
the midget and the
parasol cell systems do.
So that, then, is the procedure.
And now, we can move on and
list the perceptual functions
that one wants to test.
Now, think about it for
a minute, just quickly.
What kinds of
functions would I want
to test if I'm running
this experiment?
How can we break down
the multitude of things
that we have to process
into some basic functions?
Well, first of all,
very important function,
even though it may
have now [INAUDIBLE]
is called contrast sensitivity.
Because everything
you look at, the light
reflects just about from
everything that you look at,
and so the contrast
of the stimuli that's
on a white sheet of paper
or a gray sheet of paper
or when you look at
photographs is highly varied.
And the question
is, how well can you
see the different
levels of contrast?
Another one, of course,
that's obvious is color.
How well can you process
color information?
And then another one is pattern.
We often talk about
basic patterns.
And the one I'm going
to tell you about mostly
would be checkerboards
or something like that.
Then we talk about texture.
Most of the things that
we encounter in the world
are textured.
And so it's important for us
to be able to see texture.
Then, of course,
shape, that's obvious.
Then stereopsis.
We will talk about stereopsis
in much more detail in a bit.
What stereopsis involves, as
I've mentioned to you already,
are the difference of the
input in the two eyes.
And that difference is called
disparity, which the brain then
interprets as depth.
Another one, very important
because you often just see
things appearing quickly
in very brief times,
is to study flicker.
And yet another one
is to study motion
because that's so
central to our existence.
And then to study brightness.
And one thing I
haven't mentioned yet
is scotopic vision.
How well can you see on
the photopic and scotopic
conditions?
So those are, then,
the procedures.
And so let us now look at the
first one of these-- contrast
sensitivity.
This has been
extensively studied,
hundreds and hundreds of
papers, many of them in humans.
And most commonly in these
papers, what they did
was they used
sinusoidal gratings.
And the way you do that,
then, in similar experiments
as a detection experiment, you
present sinusoidal gratings
with spatial frequency and whose
contrast you systematically
vary.
And when you do
that, you get what
is called a contrast
sensitivity function.
And so the most common one
that you read in many papers
is plotted this way.
This is spatial
frequency low, high.
And this is contrast.
Low, high.
And then if you do that, then
you systematically studied
this in humans,
interestingly enough,
you get a function
like that-- meaning
that in between levels
of spatial frequency,
you see the best.
And extreme levels, you
don't see quite as well.
So one could use sinusoidal
gratings in animals.
But sinusoidal gratings
aren't essential.
What you can do instead is you
can present a checkerboard.
And so here's an example,
same procedure as before.
The monkey sees this and
makes a saccade to it.
It gets you water.
And then you vary
the spatial frequency
and the contrast of it.
So here is one.
You can hardly see that
because the contrast is low.
So now, to see this
overall, here's an example.
Here, we vary the contrast.
And here, we vary the
spatial frequency.
And if you look at that, you
can see that in this region,
depending on how far back
you are, this region,
you can see the best.
Here, it will be less so.
And here, of course, it
drops off dramatically,
just like that curve
I have drawn there.
So this, then, enables one to
generate a so-called "contrast
sensitivity"
function in a monkey
in those regions of the
visual field that are intact
and in those regions
of visual field
in which you have either
magnocellular or parvocellular
lesion that selectively
blocks the parasol
and the midget systems.
So that's the experiment,
then, for just studying
contrast sensitivity.
And if you do that, this is
the kind of result you get.
This is the monkey's
normal performance.
In this case, of four
spatial frequency levels.
And you go up and
down with contrast,
just like that
curve I drew there.
So this is your contrast
sensitivity function.
And it shows that
under normal conditions
and after magnocellular lesion
that blocks the parasol system,
there is no effect, meaning that
the parasol system doesn't seem
to be too important for
contrast sensitivity.
By contrast, there's
a huge effect,
especially at high
spatial frequencies,
after a parvocellular lesion
that blocks the midget system.
So that, in essence
then, is what
happens with
contrast sensitivity.
Now, let us move on and say,
well, what about color vision?
So how do you do
the color vision?
I already told you that before.
What you do is you
present, in this case,
eight stimuli, one of which
is different from the others,
and just have red
and green ones.
This is the odd one.
The monkey makes
a saccade to it.
He gets a drop of apple
juice for a reward.
Now, if you want to be
systematic about it,
you can vary the degree
of color contrast.
But the effect is so
dramatic that it was not
necessary to do that.
So let me show you
what the effect was.
Here, we have a monkey's
normal performance
when the test element
is blue, red, and green.
This happens after a
parvocellular lesion,
meaning when you block
the midget system,
the monkey cannot
see colors at all.
Just a total loss.
Whereas, after
magnocellular lesion,
his performance is
indistinguishable from normal.
So this, then,
establishes the fact
that color vision is controlled
by the midget system.
Now, the fact that this
is the case perhaps
is not that surprising
because I told you
that when you look at the
cells in the midget system
in central vision,
that most of them
get an input from
just-- at least,
the red and green ones-- get
an input from a single cone.
So just looking at the
receptive field organization
tells you that that
system is likely to be
very important for
color processing.
So that, then, is
confirmed by this kind
behavioral experiment.
So now, let us look at
brightness perception.
Now, how is that different
from contrast sensitivity?
It's different because,
in this case, what to do
then is you use a
discrimination task like this.
And I think most of you
can tell that this one is
brighter than the others.
Purposefully, I made
that a small difference,
so you can appreciate the
fact that on each trial,
we can vary the difference
between the distractors
and the target.
And you can generate
a curve seeing
how much brightness
difference do
you need to be able to perceive
a brightness difference.
So if you do that
kind of experiment,
one is in for a big surprise.
This shows here what happens
after a parvocellular lesion.
And this shows here what happens
after a magnocellular lesion.
So when you block
the midget system,
the performance is unaffected
as is the case with a magno
lesion, meaning that
if you, obviously,
that both the midget system
and the parasol system process
information about brightness,
at least, at these low spatial
frequencies that we have
used that I just showed you.
So now, the other surprise
was that, then, the question
became, well, what
if you do this not
under photopic conditions and
do under scotopic conditions?
And again, there's
no effect, meaning
that the unique
inputs from the rods
and the unique
inputs from the cones
must go into both
of the systems.
Now, the reason
that was surprising
is because a couple of
papers have been published,
maybe about 15 to 20 years ago,
that claimed that the rods feed
selectively into
the parasol system,
not into the midget system.
So this totally disprove that.
And then subsequently, careful
anatomical experiments also
established that both the
small and the large cells,
magno ganglion cells,
receive convergent input
from the rods and the
cones as I had diagrammed
to you in the previous session.
So then, let's go on and look at
pattern and texture perception.
In this case, let me show you
the kind of experiment that's
done.
This is when you
look at patterns.
One way to do it, go back
to those same checkerboards,
but make them high
contrast and have one
at a different spatial
frequency than the others.
And then you can
systematically vary the degree
of spatial frequency
difference between the targets
and the distractors.
So that would be
the method that is
used to study this kind
of pattern perception.
The other one is to
look at textures.
And in this case, those
of you in the back
probably can't see this.
But those of you up front, can
you see this little area here,
where the diagonal
lines are reversed?
So what happens is, first, you
just present this whole thing.
And then you present the reverse
patterns and the surround.
And when you do
that, the monkey has
to make a saccade
to that location
and will get a
drop of apple juice
again for that performance.
And then on each trial,
this appears somewhere else
in one of the four to eight
locations in the display.
So that's the procedure.
And then if you do
this, you, again,
luckily get a very dramatic
effect, apparently.
Here it is.
We have here normal performance.
Here's a parvocellular
lesion, magnocellular lesion.
This is texture,
and this is pattern.
Pattern tasks was, overall,
much more difficult
than the texture
one in this case.
Well, what you see here
that is really dramatic
is that when you block
the midget system,
there's a tremendous loss in
your ability to see patterns
and in your ability
to see textures.
So fine vision for
detail seems to be
central for the processing
of the midget system.
So that, then, is
the effect that one
gets with texture
and with pattern.
So now, let's move on and
talk about stereoscopic depth
perception.
It's a topic we
are going to look
at in more detail
in a later session.
Let me now introduce
this, first of all,
by telling you that stereoscopic
depth perception resulted
predominately by
virtue of the fact
that the eye is
moving to the front
so that there was a
major binocular overlap.
And if you talk about a monkey,
for example, or even many,
many animals that do have
stereoscopic vision, here's
an example of looking at a tree
when just about the only cue
you have here would be based on
stereopsis because all of them
are equally dark.
Which branch is in
front of which one?
And it's very hard to tell.
If your monkey will jump from
this branch to this branch,
if he can't tell where they
are relative to each other,
the monkey is going to
fall down and drop dread.
So it is very
important for monkeys
to have a highly functional
stereoscopic system, which
they do.
And so, how do we study this?
Well, the way we
study this is to use
what is called a
random-dot stereogram.
Random-dot stereograms
were created
once computers became a reality
many, many years back by Bela
Julesz.
And he came up with
the idea that if you
use this kinds of
random-dot stereograms,
there's no other depth cue.
So, in other words,
you can study
just the stereoscopic depth
perception aspect of it.
Now, why is this?
Because what you do here is
you look at this two displays,
you present this to the left
eye and this to the right eye.
The way this is
done is that you use
what is called a stereoscope.
I bet you most of you
have seen a stereoscope.
Everybody see a stereoscope?
No?
So a stereoscope
used to be something
that was extremely popular
starting in the 19th century.
They created these handheld
devices with the two lenses
that you look through.
And then they created a camera
that had two lenses in it
at the same distance,
roughly, as your two eyes.
And so it took a
picture, thereby,
creating two pieces,
one by each lens.
And then, what you
did, since the two have
a slightly different perspective
of what you're looking at,
then the photographs are
put into the stereoscope
to look at.
These two images are fused then.
Looks like a single image.
And due to their
very disparities,
you see real depth.
It's really dramatic.
And when we talk about
stereoscopic depth perception,
I'm going to actually bring
some stereoscopes here
and some examples so you can
see exactly what that is like.
But at any rate, in this
case, what you can do
is you can take a little
area here just like before.
And you can take the
dots in this area.
You move them a little bit
this way, a few pixels.
And you move this a
bit this way, that way.
And then if it's a
square area, you're
going to see a
square sticking out.
And the monkey will then
make a saccade to that.
But with one eye, he
cannot do anything.
He can't see a thing because
these random-dot stereograms
only give you information
about disparity.
So if you do that,
you're going to have
the monkey make a
saccade to these.
You can vary the
degree of disparity.
And when you do that,
what you find is,
quite dramatically, is that
after a parvo lesion, when
you block the midget system,
there's a tremendous loss.
The monkey
essentially, especially
at smaller disparities,
has totally
lost his ability to use
stereoscopic depth information.
So there is no deficit, however,
after a magnocellular lesion.
So therefore, you can say safely
that, especially at smaller
disparities, what you have
is the midget system that
performs this remarkable task
of seeing things in depth
by virtue of disparity
in the two eyes produced
by stereoscopic vision.
So that's really a
very dramatic effect.
Then the next thing we can
look at is motion perception.
Again, this can be
done in various ways,
but I will just show
you an example of it.
So the monkey first fixates.
Again, use random-dot
stereograms here.
And then you set in motion
a small square area.
Ready?
I hope.
There we go.
Or you can do the high
spatial frequency like that.
And then, of course, on
each trial, that appears
someplace else.
And you can vary
the velocity or you
can vary the contrast
of the display
and see how the monkey
performs in the intact portions
of visual field
and how it performs
in those portions of the
visual field that are blocked
either for the midget system
or for the parasol system.
Clear?
So let's think about
it for a minute.
What do you think
you're going to get?
Here we go.
Here we are-- motion detection.
This is a parvo lesion.
This is a magno lesion.
And so what you get is
a dramatic deficit, not
an all-amount deficit,
but a dramatic deficit
in seeing motion
after the magno lesion
but not after parvo lesion.
So this says that,
indeed, the parasol system
plays a very important role
in motion perception, not
an exclusive role.
There is still some
performance there
at very, very low contrast here.
And there's a big effect
at very high contrast,
and monkey does better.
So we can conclude
that the parasol system
is very important for
motion perception.
So now, the next thing we
can look at is flicker.
And in this case, when
you study flicker,
instead of using a
monitor, people used LEDs.
Now, why do you think that is?
Why don't they
just use monitors?
Well, I mean, the
reason for that
is very straightforward,
actually.
When you use a
regular monitor, what
is the frequency of a monitor?
It's the same as the frequency
of the alternating current
that you have, that
shine the lights up here.
But what is that in
the United States?
60 hertz.
And so that's what happens
on a regular monitor.
And every 1 over 60 hertz
is you shift the image.
In Europe, the frequency
is actually 50 hertz.
So at any rate, because
of that, there's
a rather limited
range over which
you can vary the ON and OFF
activity of a flickering spot.
So if you use any of
this, however, you
can use it in a huge,
huge range of small steps.
So, therefore, this
is what the display
looks like that people
use to study this.
First, the monkey fixates here.
And then one of these LEDs
will start flickering.
And I'll show you
the flickering, which
is not perfect here
on this monitor,
but it will give you a sense.
Everybody see that flicker?
Now, the mean flicker
value of that location
is the same as the yellow
lights that you see there.
So if it flickers
at a high rate,
you can't tell that it's
flickering because it's
beyond the ability of
the eye to resolve it,
and then you can't make a
saccade to that location.
So if you look at that, what you
find here, after parvo lesion
and after magno lesion,
you get a gigantic deficit
after magno lesion.
And that fits with what I
told you in the beginning--
namely, that the
midget cells respond
in a fairly sustained fashion
when the stimulus comes on.
Whereas, the parasol
cells respond transiently,
which makes them much more
readily available for motion
and for flicker.
So those, then, are
the major arrangements
that we see with these
various experiments.
And so we can summarize what
happens after parvocellular
and magnocellular lesion
and say what happens here.
So this one here is when
you block the midget system.
This is where you block
the parasol system.
And here are all the various
test that had been used.
And you can see that
for the parasol system,
the major deficit arises in
motion perception and flicker
perception.
So those two are very
important in the processing
of the parasol system.
Whereas, for the
midget system, you
get lots of deficits in color
vision, texture perception,
and fine pattern perception,
fine shape perception,
in contrast sensitivity,
and in stereopsis.
So this, then, gives you a sense
of what these two systems are
important for in processing
visual information.
And so, what you can do next
is to summarize what I just
told you-- namely, that
the midget system is
important for color, texture,
fine form, and fine stereo.
The parasol system is
important for fast flicker
and fast, low contrast motion.
Both systems are capable of
doing brightness; coarse form;
coarse stereo; slow
flicker; slow, high contrast
motion; and scotopic vision.
So it is not a
simple arrangement.
It's a complex arrangement.
There is overlap in what
both systems can do.
So now, the big
question comes up.
Why was it so important to
create both of these systems?
Well, the number of
schemes that have evolved,
certainly, the
motion is obvious.
But one thing one
can come up with is
a scheme of this sort that
has been proposed-- namely,
that what happened as a result
of these two systems emerging,
your ability to process
information has been extended.
And for the midget system,
you expanded the ability
to see up to high
spatial frequencies--
very, very important attribute.
And I should add, also
for the midget system,
it became possible
for you to see color.
Whereas, when you come
to the parasol system,
it expanded the
range of your ability
to process information
in the temporal domain--
your ability to see very
fast motion, to see flicker.
Now, let me add here that's
a very important attribute,
by the way, for animals as
well as humans because one
of the common things
that has emerged
in the course of evolution
is what is called camouflage.
I think I may have
mentioned that once before.
That is that when
you or an animal,
and the coloring of you,
which is done in thousands
of animals, is made similar
to the background, then
it's very difficult for you
to see that particular animal.
So it has an
excellent camouflage.
However, as soon as this
animal begins to move,
the ability to camouflage
itself disappears.
And animals have to move.
And that's because
the parasol system
is extremely
sensitive to motion.
And so whenever an
animal begins to move,
even though it has
excellent camouflage,
it is predominantly
the parasol system
that will destroy the
camouflage effect.
I'm not saying
this is necessarily
the only hypothesis, but
this is one hypothesis
that had been advanced to try
to account for how sensible it
is to have these two systems.
Now, of course,
you could ask, how
come this couldn't be just
done in one system-- all of it?
Well, there are several
reasons for that--
is that to combine a
situation where you have
a sustained response and a
transient response into one
is next to impossible.
And to have cells that
are highly sensitive,
or the parasol cells, you need
to have a convergent input
from several photoreceptors.
But as soon as
you have that, you
lose your ability
to see fine detail.
So these requirements
to do this and this
are antagonistic to each other.
And it's not possible to
do that in a single cell
at the retinal level.
So it was decided, inasmuch
as they should decide,
that it will be
best just to create
two separate systems however
complicated that might be.
So that, then, brings me
to the overall summary
of what I had covered today.
First of all, I
told you-- that's
the obvious part-- are two
major channels that originate
in the retina are the
midget and the parasol.
I should add here that there
are many other channels
in the retina,
but the cells that
do that-- and we'll
talk about some of those
later-- are much less numerous.
The overwhelming majority
of cells in the retina
are either midget and parasol.
Then in central retina,
the receptive field center
of the midget cells
and parvocellular cells
is comprised of
just a single cone.
The midget cells and the
parvocellular cells--
meaning that the midget projects
to the parvocellular layers.
And I told you before that
the midget cells of the retina
have receptive fields which are
quite similar to those, almost
identical to those that you
see in the parvocellular
layers of the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
Then the parasol cells have
much larger receptive fields
than do the midget cells.
The cone input is mixed both
in the center and the surround.
And that is the reason why this
system, the parasol system,
cannot tell you
anything about color,
but it is very sensitive and can
tell you about any change that
occurs out there over time,
irrespective of the kind
of color it has.
Now, the midget and parasol cell
ratio from center to periphery
changes from 8 to 1 to 1 to 1.
Now, I should
reiterate that in that
it is very important
for us to be
sensitive to motion
in the periphery.
That's if an animal is
threatened by some predator,
it is highly desirable
to be able to very
sensitive to any motion.
And because of that,
you have a higher number
of parasol cells in the
periphery than in the center.
And so the ratio changes to
become equal in the periphery.
Now, the midget
and parasol systems
converge on some cells in V1.
And the example,
the prime example,
I've shown you when
they were separately
blocked at the level the
geniculate, that the cell
I showed you was one that did
receive a convergent input.
But many other cells
receive single input.
V4 receives inputs from both the
midget and the parasol cells.
So it's not an area that only
deals with color, obviously.
And what it will deal with,
we'll describe in more detail
later.
The major input to MT is
from the parasol cells.
And that, often, MT
and MST have often
been called the motion areas.
But they also play
important role, by the way,
in depth perception,
as we shall see.
And then the midget
system extends the range
of vision in the wavelength and
high spatial frequency domains.
The parasol system
extends the range
of vision in the high
frequency domain.
And in the scheme
that I showed you
is what leads to this
particular conclusion.
So that, then, is the essence
of what I wanted to cover today.
And I am now certainly
open to any questions
that you might have about these
two fascinating systems that
have evolved in the
retina over the millions
and millions of
years of evolution.
Well, I was so clear that
there are questions, huh?
Well, I hope that
you sort of gotten
a sense of what it is like to
do these kinds of experiments
and how luckily, at least, in
some cases, these experiments
can lead to nice discoveries
as to the workings
of the visual system.
Now, last time when we
talked about the APB, we did
have a "magic bullet."
This approach here is
not as neat, really,
because you have to make
lesions rather than specifically
affecting certain
neurotransmitters.
And that could not be done
because the neurotransmitters
for the midget and the
parasol cells are similar.
So you can't use that
kind of procedure
that we were able to use
miraculously for the ON and OFF
channels.
So that, in essence, is what
we are going to cover today.
Did everybody sign?
Any one of you not sign
the attendance sheet?
If not, please come
up here and sign it.
And then let me just say
again that next time,
we are going to talk about
color-- another fascinating
topic.
And we are also going to
talk about visual adaptation.
And if you can, if you
get a chance to do so,
please try to read the
preparatory material which
should make it easier
for you to not only
comprehend but,
especially, to be
able to memorize these facts.
And the memorization is
a very important part
of learning things
in any course.
And it will, of
course, be essential
when you get to the stage
of having to take the exams.
Well, thank you so much.